Is he still in prison? Busy trying on a
new Batman outfit? Here's a look at why
Michael Keaton's Vulture wasn't in "No Way Home."
"Spider-Man: No Way Home" is chock full
of villains from former Spidey films,
with Alfred Molina's Doc Ock
making a grand entrance by
tearing apart a highway in pursuit of Tom
Holland's Spider-Man in the second act.
"Hello, Peter."
Stealing the show is Willem Dafoe as Norman
Osborn, who plays nice before delivering a
devastating blow as Green Goblin. Then there's
Sandman, Electro, and Lizard — one from each of
the five "Spider-Man" movies outside the Marvel
Cinematic Universe. Even Eddie Brock from the
"Venom" franchise pops up in a quick post-credits
scene, though he's far too busy getting his mind
blown by the existence of the MCU to take any real
part in the grand scheme of "No Way Home" things.
Oh, and as if that wasn't enough multiverse
goodness, the movie also gives fans the glorious
return of two previous big-screen Peter Parkers,
portrayed by Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield.
"Hi! How did you get out there?"
"Fire escape."
With all the returning villains, many were no
doubt wondering if Vulture from "Spider-Man:
Homecoming" would show up, too. In the MCU,
Michael Keaton's Vulture, aka Adrian Toomes,
is Spidey's first supervillain. He cuts a
menacing figure in the film with his giant
mechanical wings, but is, of course, foiled
by Spiderman in the end. We last saw him
in one of the "Homecoming" post-credits scenes
where he's in prison talking to Mac Gargan,
aka Scorpion, and is unwilling
to reveal Spider-Man's identity.
"If I knew who he was, he'd already be dead."
Despite the tease in that post-credits scene,
Vulture plays no part in "No Way Home."
Here's why we think he was absent.
Due to Peter botching Doctor Strange's spell,
Spider-Man villains from other universes
are pulled into the MCU timeline.
"What's happening?"
"They're starting to come
through, and I can't stop them!"
Those who know Spider-Man's
true identity come through,
which is the opposite effect of what the spell
intended. However, all members of Spider-Man's
rogues gallery who prominently feature in
the movie — as well as the figures you see
knocking at the proverbial door during the
movie's climax — have one thing in common.
They're all coming through from other universes —
and the only ones who actually make it through are
characters who have already been in different
"Spider-Man" movies. Dafoe's Green Goblin,
Molina's Doc Ock, and Church's Sandman all
hail from Sam Raimi's "Spider-Man" trilogy,
while Rhys Ifans' Lizard and Jamie Foxx's
Electro both come from Marc Webb's "The
Amazing Spider-Man" movies, and Hardy's Venom
is his own thing. The movie also seems to go
for one iconic villain per movie, which rules
out baddies like James Franco's New Goblin.
"No. He despised you. You were
an embarrassment to him."
Sure, Keaton's Vulture knows Spider-Man's
identity, but since the movie's villains are
specifically from different universes, that pretty
much rules Mr. Toomes out. After all, Vulture is
already firmly entrenched in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, so he doesn't really fit the villain
requirements to play a big role in "No Way Home."
Besides, even if he did, there's the fact that as
far as viewers know, Vulture is still in prison
after the events of "Spider-Man: Homecoming."
As "Spider-Man: No Way Home" readily
and repeatedly proves, you can never
count a good Spider-Man villain out just
because they've been defeated in one movie.
Besides, Michael Keaton's impending
return as Batman implies that the
acting legend is still perfectly willing to
operate in the world of superheroes. As such,
it might very well be that one of the reasons you
didn't see Keaton's flying villain in "Spider-Man:
No Way Home" is that he's already set
to feature in another upcoming project.
A recent trailer revealed that some
version of Vulture will likely be
in Sony's upcoming "Morbius" – at
least, judging by the fact that Keaton
appears as a man who sure seems to be Adrian
Toomes, talking to the titular Dr. Morbius.
"Hey, uh, Doctor Michael? You
and I should stay in touch."
According to The Hollywood Reporter, Keaton
is indeed playing Vulture in the movie,
even though it appears that "Morbius"
doesn't take place in the MCU. Instead,
it exists in the same universe as "Venom,"
which is certainly different from the MCU,
going by the fact that the "Venom:
Let There Be Carnage" and "Spider-Man:
No Way Home" post-credits scenes depict Eddie
Brock being transported between the two universes.
As such, it certainly seems that you will
see Keaton's Vulture sooner rather than
later — only, it's in a different corner of
the multiverse than you might have expected.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.